PROFESSOR: So what
we'll do today
is really switching to the
computational description
and characterization of
thermodynamic properties.
As we have seen in a lot
of the previous lectures
that we have been focusing
on finding out good energy
models, that is being
able to calculate,
what is the energy
of a system given
the coordinates of its ions?
And now what we want
to understand, really,
is, what is the evolution of
the system in the presence
of a finite temperature?
Temperature really
means that there
is an average kinetic
energy available for all
the atoms and the
molecules in your system.
That means that there is
really a microscopic dynamics.
And we want to follow that.
One of the most
important things--
and this goes back to, really,
the first lecture that you have
seen in this class
for the quantum part--
is that there is the fundamental
de Broglie relation that
gives us an estimate of what
is the quantum wavelength
of any kind of object.
Remember, we have said that the
wavelength times the momentum
should be equal to
the Planck constant.
And that really means that for
an object like an electron,
the de Broglie wavelength that
comes out from that relation
is comparable to the
distance between the atoms.
So if the wavelength
of an electron
is of the order of the angstrom,
10 to the minus 10 meters,
it means that the wavelike
properties of the electrons
needs to be studied.
And the electron will
behave as a wave.
And that's why we
use the Schrodinger
equation to describe electrons.
The wavelength of the nuclei
is much, much smaller.
That means that
nuclei really didn't--
we don't really need
to take into account
to a good approximation the
quantum nature of the nuclei.
The wavelength is
so small that they
can be treated
practically, correctly,
as classical particles.
And that's why, actually,
nuclei, in a way,
still follow the rules
of classical dynamics.
That is, they evolve
in time following
Newton's equation of motion.
Again, this is an
approximation that
involves treating the nuclei
as classical particles
and not as quantum particles.
But especially at
high temperature,
this is a very
good approximation.
And so a lot of approaches
in computational and material
science have to do with solving
Newton's equation of motion
for a system of
interacting nuclei
and evolving those
nuclei in time
to study the thermodynamic
properties of the system.
And so that's why I actually
started with a reminder
of Newton's equation of motion.
That is really an ordinary
second-order differential
equation.
That is, when you have a
particle of mass m in a force
field that is this
F of r, well, we
can calculate its
trajectory-- that
is, its position--
as a function of time
and its velocity as
a function of time
by integrating this
differential equation.
And in the classical case
that is always presented,
say, is the evolution of a
particle in a constant force
field, like a particle under
the gravitational law, that,
to a large extent, is constant
if you don't move very much.
And because, in that case, the
force is really a constant,
the integration of
this becomes trivial.
It's really a second
derivative that
needs to be equal a constant.
And integrating that
gives us a parabola.
But the reason why
I'm focusing on this
is to remind you of the initial
conditions in our differential
equations.
That is, if we have a
second-order differential
equation, the general solution--
let's say in this case
for this force field would
be a parabola-- is uniquely
identified once we specify the
position at a certain instant
and the velocity at
a certain instant.
That is, among all the possible
parabolas in the world,
you selected the one
that your projectile
is going to follow once
you have the position
and the velocity at
a certain instant.
And that's why actually
dynamics and molecular dynamics
and other physical properties
basically depend essentially
on the position of the
particle in your system
and the velocity of the
particle in your system.
That's why there is no physical
observable that depends, say,
on the fifth derivative
with respect to time.
It's really because the
dynamics of that system
follows Newton's
equation of motion.
OK, with this, what we really
need to deal in general
is with a system of
interacting particles.
And for a moment
you could actually
think that this i,
interacting particles,
could be the planets
orbiting around the sun.
So each of the planet i will
have its own trajectory.
Our r of t will
have its own mass.
And they all live
in a force field.
That's really where the
many-body complexity, again,
comes out.
So many-body complexity,
that is much easier
to deal with than the many-body
complexity of the electron
problem because, again, now
we describe each object just
with a set of six variables,
so its 3-space coordinate
and its 3-momentum coordinate.
But still, each and every object
interacts with each other.
When you look at the planets
orbiting around the sun,
you, at first
approximation, could only
consider the gravitational
attraction to the sun.
But in reality, also the planets
interact with each other.
And so, again, even if
this is much simpler
than the Schrodinger
equation, as soon
as you start to have more
than two bodies interacting,
it really becomes too complex
to solve analytically.
And so all the molecular
dynamic techniques
have, as their only
object, basically,
the integration in time
of this equation of motion
in an efficient form.
There are a couple of comments
that one wants to make.
In general, we deal with
conservative fields.
That is, the force
depends on position only.
That also means that
the work that you
make in going from one point
to another point, the integral
of the force times
the displacement
is going to be independent
from the trajectory.
So the energy, if
you want, is just
a function of the position.
The other thing that
descends immediately
from this equation of motion
is that the total energy
of the system is conserved.
And that's very easy to prove.
And I'll do it in a moment.
And that's what's often called
a microcanonical evolution.
When you read about
microcanonical ensembles,
it means that you are
actually under the condition
in which the total energy
of your system is conserved.
And again, what is the
total energy of your system?
Well, if you have one
particle, it's just, trivially,
the kinetic energy
1/2 mv squared
plus the potential energy
V of r of that particle,
and just doing everything
in one dimension.
And you ask, why is this
going to be conserved?
Well, you can just prove it
by taking the time derivative
of this quantity, OK?
So we have taken kinetic
energy plus potential energy.
We look at the time derivative.
And this is just simple algebra.
What you get is 1/2 m times 2
times v times the derivative
with respect to time,
that is the acceleration,
plus the derivative of the
potential with respect to time.
And this can just be written
as mass times velocity times
acceleration plus--
and we can rewrite
the derivative
of the potential with
time as the derivative
respect to position
times the derivative of the
position with respect to time.
And now you see where
we are getting to,
because this term here is
equal to minus the force,
while these terms here
is equal to the velocity.
And so it goes away with here.
And so what we have is
that m, the derivative
of the total energy
with respect to time,
is equal to the mass times
acceleration minus the force.
That is 0 because
the particle follows
Newton's equation of motion.
So because of Newton's
equation of motion
and because the particle
follows exactly that evolution,
we have that the sum
of the kinetic energy
plus the potential
energy needs to be
conserved during the evolution.
And that's actually the
fundamental sanity check
that you will always
have and you can always
do during a molecular
dynamics simulation.
That is, you can check
that your integration is
correct by making sure that
the total energy of your system
is concerned.
OK, so what do we do in a
practical molecular dynamic
simulation?
Well, the idea is that, as
in the motion of the planets,
we want to integrate
the equation of motions
with this caveat that, again,
each particle interacts
with each other particle.
And so it's really
a many-body problem,
even if it is a classical
many-body problem.
And so it's really
easier to integrate
than a many-body
Schrodinger equation.
And in general, the
way particles interact
with each other can be described
by empirical force fields
or, in the best-case
scenario, can be described
using quantum mechanics.
That is the [? functional ?]
theory [INAUDIBLE]..
And so what you will
have to do in that case
is that for every configuration
of your ionic system,
you need to solve an entire
total energy self-consistent
problem.
And that's why actually
the first principle
in molecular dynamics becomes a
very, very expensive challenge.
And we'll see in one
of the later classes
how this is solved.
There are a lot of systems that
can be described accurately,
even with very simple potential.
Even more than in the
case of the total energy,
certain thermodynamic
transitions,
like the transition from
a solid to a liquid,
can be thought of as broadly
independent of the details
of the interacting potentials.
So even studying a system with
a Lennard-Jones potential that,
after all, was developed
especially to do molecular
dynamic simulations
of rare gas atoms,
or even just studying a system
that is made by hard spheres
that don't really interact
when they travel in space,
apart when they really
hit each other--
so what is called a contact
interaction that is 0 all
the time apart from the instant
in which the two spheres
collide--
can sometimes give you a
very accurate qualitative
description of the thermodynamic
transition in a problem.
And molecular dynamics actually
was first introduced really
to study systems, like liquids,
for which it's very difficult
to develop analytic techniques.
You see, if you want
to study a solid,
you can actually
choose a potential.
And if the potential
is simple enough,
you can analytically
calculate the potential energy
of a periodic repetition
of all your atoms.
But if you study
liquid, disorder
is really an essential part
of the state of the system.
And so the entropic
contribution to the free energy
of the system is fundamental.
And really there are no
reasonable analytic ways
to address a lot of the
questions that you have.
And that's why
people really moved
to solving on the computer
the Newton equation of motion.
And this is a short history,
really, of molecular dynamics,
reminding you what is the
history of computers, really.
In 1952, one of the
first computers, MANIAC,
was operational in Los Alamos.
And that's when Metropolis,
Nicholas Metropolis,
in collaboration with
actually a husband and wife
couple, Rosenbluth and
Rosenbluth and Teller
and Teller, developed what is
called the Monte Carlo method.
That was a very powerful
method to address
exactly this entropic
free energy problem.
And that you'll see in
one of the later classes.
But really, 1956 sees the first
molecular dynamic simulation
by Alder and Wainwright.
And as I said, in looking at
the dynamics of hard spheres,
these are the milestone papers.
Vineyard is studying
radiation damage
in copper, what happens when
you have a copper atom that
is really put in
motion by a very
energetic radiation kicking it
and starting running around.
And really this is
the classic paper
of Aneesur Rahman studying,
with a Lennard-Jones potential,
the dynamics of liquid argon.
Again, a Lennard-Jones potential
is actually very accurate
to describe rare
gases that ultimately
repel each other at
very close distance
and, at large distances,
attract each other
with this weak dipole-dipole
interaction that goes as 1
over r to the 6th.
And then really the first
ab-initio molecular dynamics
and the first theory for
was developed in the mid
'80s by Car and Parrinello.
OK, now, there is
a universal way
to think of these dynamics of
your classical system composed
of N particles.
And as we have said,
since they follow
Newton's equation of motion,
what we really need to track,
the only quantities
that we need to track,
is their position as
a function of time
and their velocity as
a function of time.
And generally speaking,
the kinetic energy
is just a function
of the velocities.
And the potential energy is just
a function of the positions.
So if you have N
particles, you really
have to follow in
time six n variables.
And if we define for a moment
a six-dimensional space, what
we really have is that
an instantaneous state
of your dynamical system, that
is all its position and all
its velocity, can be represented
by a single point in this 6N
dimension of space.
So if you have got just
a hydrogen molecule
with two nuclei,
what you really need
is a point in six dimensions.
If you have a
water molecule, you
need a point in nine dimensions.
And the evolution-- sorry.
If you have a
water molecule, you
need a point in 18 dimensions.
And if you have a
hydrogen molecule,
you need a point
in 12 dimensions.
And the dynamical
evolution of your system
is described exactly by the
evolution of this point.
So we often think at this
phase space that we'll have,
for an N particle, 6N
dimension, of which--
let's try to draw
a bit dimension--
3N of them, those
represented in green,
will really represent
the positions.
And the other 3N will
represent velocities.
OK.
And obviously this is
all orthogonal dimension.
And your point
will be somewhere.
The certain instant in time T
will have a set of velocities,
will have a set of positions.
And the Newton
equation of motion
will make it evolve
in this phase space.
So really your molecular
dynamic integration
consists in following
in time this evolution.
And that evolution
is, in principle,
analytically and
uniquely defined
once you know the position
and the velocities
at every instant.
And-- well, we'll
see that later.
OK, so what do we
do once we have
a computational algorithm
that allows us to evolve
this point in phase space?
And I sort of summarized
here the three main goals
that could follow from a
molecular dynamic simulation
in the order that
we'll see them.
Really, one of the
most common ones
is to use molecular
dynamic simulations
to calculate thermodynamic
properties, that
is to calculate what we
call ensemble averages.
Suppose that you have
a system like a solid.
And you have calculated,
say, its lattice parameter,
like you're doing
in lab 2 or lab 3.
And suppose that you start
heating up this solid.
What happens?
Well, the atoms, in
the classical sense,
start oscillating more and more.
And you know from
experience that most solids
start expanding when
you warm them up.
So a molecular
dynamic simulation
could tell you how much a solid
expands when you heat it up
because basically you start
evolving your system from 0
temperature.
And then you increase
its temperature.
And really,
temperature, remember,
is just the average
kinetic energy of the ions.
And as you increase
the temperature,
the ions oscillate
more and more.
And if you let your unit
cell expand or contract
in time following what
is the stress overall
of all the atoms
in your unit cell,
you see that your
system increases
the dimension of the unit cell
and starts oscillating around
a value that's
really an average,
depending on temperature.
And all these sort of statements
can be actually made formally
in a way that we'll
see in a moment that is
the language of thermodynamics.
That is, if we have
a finite temperature,
we'll have a certain
probability associated
with every microscopic
configuration.
OK, so if you are
at 0 temperature,
really what you have is
that you have a probability
1 to be in the lowest energy
state possible and probability
0 of being in any
other energy state.
If you start increasing
your temperature,
states that are energetically
similar to the ground
state but not really
the ground state
start to have a certain
probability of being occupied.
And the more
temperature you have,
the more very costly
configurations
can be accessed by your system.
And really, the
average properties
at a finite
temperature need to be
an average over all these
possible states weighed
with their appropriate
thermodynamic weight, weighed
with the probability
of being in that state.
And so this is what an
ensemble average does really.
It tries to span all the
possible states in a system
with a probability
that is proportional to
their thermodynamical weight.
And then for each state, you can
calculate a certain property,
like what is its average
potential energy, what
is its lattice
parameter, and so on.
And out of that,
you can calculate
the average
thermodynamic property.
And we'll see, actually,
an example in a moment.
So we'll see a practical
application of this.
The other thing that you can
do with molecular dynamic
simulator is actually
study the evolution
in real time of your system.
So you could actually
study a chemical reaction.
What happens if you have, say,
an explosive molecule that
is decomposing, OK?
And in particular, whenever you
have a chemical reaction that
tends to be a bond-breaking
and bond-forming reaction,
you'll probably need to use a
quantum mechanical approach.
But in principle, you
can set up your system
in an initial
configuration and see what
happens as you evolve in time.
You could look at a
catalytic reaction.
Say, maybe you are interested
in studying fuel cells.
And you want to see how a
hydrogen molecule decomposes
when it arrives on
a platinum surface.
Well, you can take
your hydrogen molecule
and project it delicately
towards the platinum surface.
And follow, with your
molecular dynamic techniques,
the dynamics of all these nuclei
as the molecule chemisorbs
and dissociates in time.
And then really the
last application
of molecular dynamics is more
of an optimization algorithm.
There are problems in
which it's very complex
to find what is the lowest
possible solution, what
is the optimal solution.
That is, you could
try to find out
what is the schedule of all your
flights in an airplane company.
And obviously that's a
complex optimization problem
because you can't move
one plane at a time
and figure out what is the best
possible solution because there
might be a completely
different choice of planes
and itineraries that
actually gives you a best
performance overall on the net.
And so you can always take
one optimization problem
and express a cost function.
That is depending on
what is your interest.
Minimize the amount of
oil, let's say, used
in running all these routes.
So when you have a cost function
of a very complex problem,
you have really an object
that depends on many variables
and that has a lot
of possible minima.
OK, so this would be,
really, the problem
of optimizing the air
routes of an airline.
What you have is a lot
of possible variables.
And there are a lot of
reasonable solutions.
But you really want to find the
one that is the best for you,
something like this.
And molecular
dynamics can actually
help to solve this
problem because it's
a problem that is absolutely
analogous of having
a system of interacting
particles that
has a certain potential
energy surface
and trying to explore that
potential energy surface,
moving around, until you
find the lowest minimum.
You could think of this
as a mountain range.
And you have your
skiers that are really
your particles moving around.
And you want to sort
of let the skiers ski
around as much as possible until
they find the minimum energy
state.
And so you can use a
thermodynamic analogy.
You heat up your system.
That really means
that every particle
has a lot of kinetic energy.
So having a lot
of kinetic energy
can easily overcome any
kind of potential barrier.
And you have a lot of these
particles moving around.
And then you cool
them down slowly.
And as you cool
them down, they'll
start piling up in the
lowest possible energy state.
And once you have reached,
very slowly, 0 temperature,
you look at where all your
particles have ended up.
And so you have at
least a good sampling
of the relevant minima in
your potential energy surface.
So actually molecular dynamics--
and this is called simulated
annealing, in this context--
can actually be used as
an optimization technique.
And we don't have to go as
far as the case of an airline
or what is called the
traveling salesman problem.
But often what we
have is that we
have a system that is fairly
complicated to characterize.
Say we want to describe
maybe an interface
between a perfect silicon
crystal and the SiO2 substrate
because we are in the
electronic industry.
Well, I mean, we have a
problem because how do we
construct the interface
between a crystalline solid
and an amorphous system?
I mean, we can try putting
atoms in a reasonable position.
But it's never going
to work very well.
And so what we
can do is actually
use molecular dynamic techniques
to let the atoms evolve
according to their
interaction and to the Newton
equation of motion and
somehow find, by themselves,
a slightly more favorable
green minima instead
of the initial configuration
in which we have put them.
OK, so, in principle, if you
had infinite computing power
or infinite
mathematical prowess,
you would have really
solved the problem
of characterizing on a computer
any material that you wanted.
The reason why you
can't really do
that in general and
indiscriminately
has to do with four problems
that arise in the approach
that I've mentioned.
And I've mentioned them here, I
guess, in order of importance.
And the first and
most dramatic problem
is the one of time scales.
That is, atoms move around and
vibrate at time scales that
are characteristic of atoms.
That is, say, in a
molecule, it will
take tens of femtoseconds
or hundreds of femtoseconds
to have a periodic oscillation.
So these are femtoseconds.
10 to the minus 15
seconds is the order
of magnitude of the dynamics of
the atoms at room temperature.
Now, a lot of
interesting problems
take place in times of
seconds, minutes, or hours.
A classical problem is
how a protein folds itself
in its native state.
And you know, this is a
process that can take seconds.
And so we have,
really, the issue
that all our calculation takes
place on the timescales of 10
to the minus 15.
And often we need to reach
physical properties that
are of the order of seconds.
So we need to span a
15 order of magnitude.
And that means that if it
takes a time x to perform
one single molecular
dynamic operation,
we have a 10 to the 15 cost
to get to the reasonable time
scale for a lot of
macroscopic processes.
And that's really a scale
that we can't bridge.
If we do quantum mechanical
simulations for a small system,
we can easily reach
the times of tens
of picoseconds or
hundreds of picoseconds.
If we do classical molecular
dynamic simulation,
we can go maybe three, four,
five orders of magnitude
better.
And so we can start
accessing nanoseconds
and maybe start getting closer
towards the microsecond.
But there is still an
enormous gap to reach.
And this is really
a difficult problem
to overcome because we
have dynamics taking place
at different levels.
Say, think of a protein.
We have the atomic dynamics
of an atom vibrating around.
And then we have dynamics of
subunits maybe interacting
with the different amino
acids along the chain.
And then we have structural
motifs that want to move around
and then maybe the first coil-up
in a certain configuration.
But that's not really very good.
And then after a while
they sort of open up
and recoil in a
different configuration.
And so the more you look at your
system on a larger and larger
length scale, the
more you discover
that there are dynamics of
more and more complex groups
that are slower and slower.
And integrating from the atomic
motion up to the mesoscale
and the macroscopic
scale of these dynamics
is really an impossible
problem to do by brute force.
And I would say that it's
still the conceptual problem
for which less
progress has been made.
It's really the
most difficult one.
And you'll hear a
lot of talks nowadays
in science about
multiscale modeling
and about bridging timescales.
And it's obviously a
very important challenge.
But I still think we are
at the stage in which there
are very little solutions.
Somehow related to the
time-scale problem,
there is the length
scale problem.
Suppose you want to study
a system close to a phase
transition.
Suppose that you want
to see a gas evaporate.
You want to study a
liquid-to-vapor transition.
What happens exactly
at the temperature
where the liquid and the
vapor are in equilibrium?
Suppose that you are
studying water boiling.
At normal condition,
it boils at 373 Kelvin.
And at that temperature, why
there is a phase transition?
Basically because
the free energy
of the liquid and the free
energy of the gas are the same.
You go a little bit
above the temperature,
the free energy of
the gas is lower.
So the system wants
to be all gas.
You go a little bit below
the boiling temperature,
the free energy of
the liquid is lower.
So the system wants
to be a liquid.
But as you get closer and
closer to the temperature,
these two free energies
becomes comparable.
That means that the cost
of transforming from liquid
to the gas and
from gas to liquid
becomes smaller and smaller.
And it is 0 at the
transition temperature.
That means, in practice, that
since it doesn't cost anything
to transform from one
state to the other,
you have lost all
possible length
scale because you can nucleate
a bubble of gas of any size
with 0 cost.
So if you think of
the transformation
from a liquid to a vapor as
the nucleation of bubble of gas
exactly at the temperature
of the transition,
that cost has become 0.
And we can nucleate
bubbles of any size.
So the phase
transition is a moment
where we lose length scales.
The fluctuation
can have any size.
And so any kind of
finite simulation
will break down
because it's really
only in the infinite system that
we represent appropriately all
these sizes popping
up in our system.
And so that's why
it becomes very
difficult to study
accurately, say, a boundary
at a phase transition.
We say that the length
scale starts diverging.
And that's why one
needs to be careful.
This problem is not as serious
as the problem of time scales.
But it's still one that you
want to consider very carefully
and one you need to spend
some time thinking, actually.
That is, often we use a
periodic boundary condition
to describe an extended system.
And so the question
that you always
have to ask yourself is, how
large should I make my unit
system that is periodically
repeated before it's really
describing accurately
the infinite system that
is the goal of my simulation?
Suppose that you want
to study water, OK?
Or suppose that you want
to study any liquid.
In principle you want
an infinite system.
In principle you can deal
only with a finite number
of degrees of freedom.
So the two possibilities
that you have,
you could study a
droplet of water, OK?
But then obviously you
encounter the problem
that, when you
study a droplet, you
have a very large influence
coming from the surface effect.
A droplet is a droplet because
of the surface tension.
And before reaching
the thermodynamic limit
of that droplet behaving
as a bulk liquid,
you need really to
go to enormous sizes.
If instead you study, say,
the same number of molecules
in periodic boundary
conditions, you
eliminate the presence
of the surface.
And so you can reach
the thermodynamic limit
of the system behaving
as a bulk much faster.
But still you need to
always ask your question,
is your simulation
still large enough?
And there is a size
that is large enough.
And that's the other
very important concept.
That is, whenever your
simulation cell is so large
that the dynamics of
one water molecule
doesn't affect the dynamics
of a water molecule
that is far away from
yours as much as it
is its periodic image, your
system has become infinite.
That is, whenever you have
a molecule in a liquid,
you really dynamically interact
not with every other molecule
in the infinite liquid but only
with a sphere of neighbors.
And you need to
understand how large
is that sphere of neighbors
because those and only those
are the molecules
that affect yourself
in the center of that sphere.
And if you decide that for
a water molecule at room
temperature the sphere of
neighbors with which there
is a dynamic interaction
has only a radius of 10
angstroms, whenever your unit
cell is larger, is a cube,
say, larger than 20
angstroms inside,
you are studying, in
practice, an infinite system
because every molecule
in that system
sees all the independent
neighbors that it needs to see,
OK?
So even a simulation with a
finite number of molecules
can reproduce exactly the
behavior of an infinite system
provided a molecule interacts
with other independent
molecules up to a maximum
range of dynamical correlation.
And we'll actually
define this quantity
in the lecture that follows.
So again, length scales
are another problem
and a problem in which periodic
boundary conditions tend
to help a lot.
But again, suppose that
you want to study something
like the strength of a metal.
Well, you have now a problem
in which a lot of length scales
becomes intertwined because
in the strength of a metal,
you might want to consider what
is the dynamics of impurities
that strengthen that metal.
Like, if you have steel,
you have carbon atoms
in between the ions.
And so you need to understand
what is the atomic dynamics.
But then there will be dynamics
of units on a larger length
scale because in a metal there's
going to be these location
and slip and glide planes.
And so there is coordinated
motion of thousands of atoms
that you want to consider.
And then, in reality, a real
metal is never a crystal.
But it's always a
polycrystalline material.
So you have grains.
And inside that grain you
have a consistent ordering
of the atoms.
But then grains are mismatched.
And there are grain boundaries.
And so you have a
lot of length scales
to consider if you
really want to predict
what would be the mechanical
response of a real system.
OK, so this is the challenge,
if you want, number 2.
The challenge
number 3 is the one
that we have described
more in detail up to now
that is determining
how accurate can
be your prediction of the
interaction between nuclei.
And you have seen everything
that we could tell you
about empirical potential
quantum mechanical simulations.
And in principle, even if
it's obviously very expensive
to make very accurate
predictions of the interaction
between atoms, in principle
it's the less conceptually
challenging of the problems.
I mean, we can just try all our
electronic structure methods
at will.
And we can try to see
how accurate we become.
And the last challenge
that is also not
really a conceptual challenge
and it can be solved
but is just a very
expensive one to overcome
is this one in which
we treat the nuclei
as classical particles.
And that tends to be,
in general, very good.
But it's sort of an
approximation that
breaks down the more
you go towards lighter
and lighter nuclei
because, remember,
the de Broglie relation.
Your wavelength
times your momentum
is equal to the Planck constant.
So the lighter you
are, the smaller
your momentum, the longer your
wavelength, the more quantum
you become.
So something like hydrogen that
has a nucleus that is just one
proton, so it's fairly light--
or it's the lightest of all
possible nuclei--
tend to still have
significant quantum properties
even at relatively
high temperatures.
You see, the more you
increase the temperature,
the more the average momentum
of your particles become
and the more
classical they become.
But the lower the temperature,
the more quantum they become.
And something like hydrogen
is still significantly
quantum at room temperature.
And what does that mean?
Well, it means
that that particle,
it's really a delocalized
system that can actually
tunnel through barriers.
That's if you want one of
the important differences
between a particle
that behaves according
to classical mechanics and
one that behaves according
to quantum mechanics.
If you are behaving as
a classical particle,
you need to have enough kinetic
energy to overcome a barrier.
If you are a skier and
you are in a valley
and you want to go
in the other valley,
you need to have
enough velocity to be
able to overcome the mountain.
If you are a quantum
skier, you can actually
have some finite probability
of tunneling through.
And so there are tunneling
problems that are important
not only for hydrogen
but sometimes
even for much more
massive particles
or even for groups of
particles, provided
that the energy barrier
that they need to overcome
is small enough.
And I've shown you in the
first quantum class an example
in a perovskite crystal in which
we have this cubic structure
with an octahedral
cage of oxygen
that can configure itself
in a ground state that
is ferroelectric, in which
the oxygen cage displaces
with respect to
the cubic symmetry
and induces a permanent
electrical dipole
in your system.
Well, there are
certain materials
that have this structure.
But since the
octahedral cage can
have roughly six
possible choices on where
to move offsite, if you
decrease the temperature enough,
the oxygen cage
will start actually
tunneling between all
the six possibilities.
Instead of finding
itself at 0 temperature
in a broken symmetry
configuration in which
the oxygen cage has chosen one
of those six possibilities,
in reality, because
of quantum tunneling,
it keeps tunneling between
all the six possibilities.
And on average your
system looks cubic.
And on average you don't have
really any ferroelectricity.
But the polarizability
of the system
is going to be different
from that one in which
the octahedral cage was
sitting squarely in the cube.
So there is a dielectric
response that is different.
So there are cases that are
fairly exotic, I would say,
for most applications, in which
tunneling effects of the nuclei
could become important.
But there is one other
important consequence
that comes from
quantum mechanics that
tends to be important
in a lot of cases.
And that consequence has
to do with the quantization
of vibrational excitations.
That is, if you look at
the motion of any system--
a molecule, a solid--
in classical terms, well,
that molecule or that solid
can have any amount
of kinetic energy.
In a hydrogen
molecule, the atoms
can have 0 kinetic energy
if we treat it classically.
Or they can move
just a little bit.
So they have a very minute
amount of kinetic energy.
And we can just increase
the kinetic energy
that those atoms
can have at will.
In reality, because the
system is a quantum system,
the vibrational
modes of a molecule
or the vibrational modes of a
solid are actually quantized.
And you can't have arbitrary
amounts of vibrational energy.
Actually, in its
quantum ground state,
a molecule will not be at rest.
But it will be in what is called
the zero-point motion state.
That is what is the quantum
mechanical ground state.
You can think of the
analogy with the stability
of the atoms.
In its ground state, the
electron around the proton
is not collapsing onto
the proton because
of the Coulombic repulsion.
If the electron was
a classical particle,
it would collapse
on the nucleus.
And the hydrogen atom would be
just a proton and an electron
sitting in the same place.
But because the
electron is quantum,
it can't really collapse.
And its lowest energy
state is a state
that is the 1s orbit for the
hydrogen in which the electron
is around the atom but
doesn't collapse onto it.
And the excitation of that
electron to the next energy
state is a quantized excitation.
You can't go to a
level of 1s that
has an energy for the
hydrogen of minus 1
Rydberg to another state
that has energy minus 0.99
or minus by 0.98 or
any kind of amount.
The next state in which
the electron can live
is a state that has an energy
of minus 1/4 and then minus 1/9
and so on and so forth.
The same thing happens for the
vibrational level of molecules,
OK?
A quantum molecule
in its ground state
is not in a state where
the atoms do not move.
But it's in a state where the
atoms have a certain amount
of quantum kinetic energy.
And it's in a state
called zero-point motion.
And if you want to
increase the kinetic energy
of this molecule, you
can't do it continuously.
There is a quantized cap.
So you need to
provide enough energy
to heat up the system
to the next state
and then to the next state
and then to the next state.
And that, if you think,
affects deeply how you
are going to heat up a system.
That is, if you look at the
specific heat of a solid,
that is basically the
quantity that tells you
how much heat the system is
going to be able to take,
and you look at what happens
at very low temperature,
you discover that actually the
system is almost unable to take
any heat because all the
vibrational excitation are
much larger than the average
amount of kinetic energy
that you have if you
are looking at what
it takes to bring something
from 1 Kelvin to 2 Kelvin.
OK, but this is still
relevant if you have a system
like water, even at 300 Kelvin.
In water, say, at 300
Kelvin, what you have is
you have these water molecules.
Remember what you have-- your
oxygen, hydrogen, and hydrogen.
And the modes of vibration
of these molecules
are stretching modes
of the hydrogens.
And then there are
scissor-like models
in which the two bonds do this.
And then these are
intermolecular modes, just sort
of relevant to one molecule.
And then there are all
the molecules interacting.
Well, at room temperature,
all the internal modes
of the molecule, the stretching
and the scissor modes,
have so much vibrational
energy in their ground state
that it's almost
impossible to excite them
to the next vibrational state
with the average temperature
that you have at 300 Kelvin.
So even a system as
fundamental as water
has really a hybrid
behavior in which
the vibrational interaction
between molecules
can actually be
populated arbitrarily
by the temperature that
is surrounding you.
But it's almost impossible
to excite a molecule
from a zero-point stretching
motion to the next one.
And so, say, the
specific heat of water
will be slightly exotic because
really part of its vibration
are quantized.
And so there are
a number of cases
in which this classical nuclear
approximation is not exact.
And luckily they can be studied
with specific techniques
that we'll see in some of
the later-application classes
during this course.
But remember this-- if there
is one thing that you want
to remember about the
behavior of nuclei--
that this vibrational
excitation are quantized.
And we actually see
this quantization
in physical properties
like the specific heat.
OK, so let's discuss the first
of the possible applications
of molecular dynamics
that I have mentioned.
And that's using
molecular dynamics
to really calculate average
properties of a system
at finite temperatures.
And what I have written
here is really the summary
of statistical mechanics.
So that is what, if you want,
Boltzmann would tell you.
You have a dynamical
system that is
described by this point moving
around in phase space, OK?
So with a certain
possible set of positions
and with a certain
possible set of momenta.
And suppose that we
want to calculate, say,
what is an average property
at a certain temperature.
And we call that property
A. It could be the lattice
parameter of the system.
Or it could be the diameter,
say-- it's even simpler--
of your water bubble.
OK, you have this water bubble.
And you want to see what is the
diameter of this water bubble
at a certain temperature.
And this diameter is going
to increase with temperature.
And what you do, you just
let this system evolve.
And during its
evolution, you keep
measuring what is its diameter.
And you let this evolve a lot.
And you measure
what is its width.
Well, the way Boltzmann would
set this problem is say,
we really need to integrate
over all possible configurations
of the system.
That is, we need to go through
all possible configurations
of the system.
That is, we need to integrate
over the full phase space.
And for every possible
point in phase space,
we need to calculate the
diameter of my water bubble.
And then we need to
take into account
what is the probability of
being in that configuration.
And if you are in a system
at a constant temperature,
the probability of finding
yourself at a given temperature
is given by exponential
of minus beta is just 1
over the Boltzmann
constant times
the temperature
times the energy.
That means that
configurations that
have a high internal
energy are very unlikely.
And configurations
that have lower energy
are more likely, to the point
that if the temperature is
0, that is this beta is
diverging to infinity,
only the lowest energy
configuration possible is
represented.
So this is the statistical
mechanic points.
To calculate an average quantity
at a finite temperature,
we need to sum over all
possible configurations
in space and momentum.
For each possible r
and p configuration,
we'll have a certain value of
the diameter of that bubble.
We weigh that with
the statistical weight
of that configuration.
And we actually normalize
this expectation value.
And this is what we obtain.
So if, for a moment, you
think at a phase space that
is two dimensional
and in this square
we represent all the possible
positions and velocities
of our system, what
Boltzmann tells
us is that for every
possible point,
we will have a
certain value of A.
And the sum of all
the possible values
of A weighted with the
probability of finding them
gives us the expectation value.
And so what you
really need to do
is an integral over
all space of this.
And the cost of these
integrals diverges
as the number of
dimensions diverge
because, again, every time we
increase the size of the system
by one particle, we have six
more dimensions over which
to integrate.
And again, if you
think that we do
this just by
numerical integrations
by taking points
on a grid and maybe
we just discretize our system
with 10 points along one
dimension, every time
you add a particle,
you have 10 to the 6 points
that multiply your system.
So this quantity explodes.
The point of view of molecular
dynamics is different.
What we say is that, well, let's
just let this system evolve.
Let this system evolve in time.
And let it evolve at a
constant temperature.
And so now our
point in phase space
is going to go around,
following a trajectory.
And if we let it go
around long enough,
it will spend more time in
the parts of phase space that
are more favorite, the
ones that are more likely,
according to the
Boltzmann factor.
And so if our evolution,
really, is distributed
in the trajectory according
to this thermodynamic weight,
thermodynamic factor, then
our expectation value,
the thermodynamic average
for our observable A,
is just trivial,
obtained by integrating
over the trajectories
all the values
of A. That is what
I was saying before.
If you want to calculate the
diameter of your bubble, what
you do in the molecular
dynamic sense,
you just let the
bubble evolve according
to the equation of motion
at a constant temperature.
And you keep monitoring
its diameter.
And you will see that the
diameter will have an average
and that this is a much more
efficient way then considering
all possible configurations
of the bubble,
weighing them with how
expensive that configuration is,
and doing it for all the
possible configurations.
The molecular dynamic algorithm
automatically, if you want,
keeps spanning the most
likely configurations.
And so it does, for you, the
job of going in the place where
it's most likely to be.
So in order to calculate
a sample average,
we can actually
transform a problem
into integration
over a trajectory.
And that is almost always
doable under what is called
the criterion of ergodicity.
So the equivalence between
the two formulations
that I'd written before--
that is calculating
a thermodynamic observable
as an integral in phase space
or as an integral over
trajectories-- are equivalent,
provided your trajectory
is really able
to go all over the
place in phase space.
So if, again, this
were phase space,
you could have, in
principle, the problem
of a known ergodic
system if there
is something that
prevents your trajectory
to reach certain so-called
forbidden segments
in your phase space.
And I can give you an example.
Suppose that you are studying
something like silicon
and you are in the
crystalline state.
And now you heat it up.
And once you go above
the melting temperature,
your silicon will
become liquid, OK?
Now, suppose that you cool
it down again below, now,
the melting temperature.
OK, in principle,
the liquid silicon
should become again
crystalline silicon
because, at that temperature in
which we have brought it back
to, the thermodynamic
stable state is really
the crystalline solid.
If you do that in practice
with our molecular dynamic
simulation, you see that
you start from the crystal.
You heat it up.
It becomes a liquid
with no problems.
And then you cool it back down.
And instead of going
back to a crystal,
it goes back to a
glassy, amorphous state.
Silicon will find itself
in a configuration
in which locally all
atoms are happy to be
fourfold coordinated.
But if we look at the long-range
order, it's completely lost.
The system is not
crystalline anymore.
It's glassy.
What's happening there?
Well, it happens that it's
just, for a liquid cooling
down, so much easier
to trap itself
into a set of configurations in
which atoms are really fairly
happy as they are,
because what is important
for silicon atoms is to
be fourfold coordinated.
But what is important
to be in a crystal
is that this fourfold
coordination extends
and becomes a long-range order.
But for silicon, it's very
inexpensive to mess up
that long-range order, like
for many other systems.
And in principle, same
thing happens for polymers.
You lower it down.
And they sort of get trapped
in a glassy configuration.
A lot of polymers might
want to stay actually
in a crystalline state.
But really that is
impossible to reach.
And so if you want
to study, say,
what are the properties
of your silicon
and you have obtained or you are
trying to obtain your silicon
structure from a liquid that you
cooled down, you'll actually--
in your molecular
dynamics, you'll
keep orbiting around in
this glassy mass state
and will never reach that
region of phase space
that is actually very,
very small because it
needs to have all atoms
long range in very
specific positions.
And so you are really spanning
a system in a nonergodic way.
That is, you spend a lot of
time in a region of phase space
that are not really
representative but out of which
is very difficult to escape.
OK, so there are
problems in, again,
brute force molecular
dynamic approaches that you
have to be careful about.
OK, so let's see
how we actually go
and try to do this on
our computer experiment.
And I'll start with
the simplest case
that is what is called
the microcanonical case.
That is, we perform a simulation
where the number of particles
is constant, the
volume is constant,
and the total energy of
the system is constant.
This is what is called a
thermodynamic ensemble.
Again, these are all
extensive variables.
And we are fixing them.
Sometimes it's
appropriate, instead,
to do a Legendre
transformation and go
into a different
thermodynamic ensemble.
Say, you could want not to
be at a constant volume.
But you might want to study a
system at a constant pressure
where the volume changes.
And so we need to describe
how we'll actually
be able to do that.
That is, how will
we be able to move
to a system in which different
intensive thermodynamic
variables are constant?
But if you take a system of
particles in periodic boundary
conditions and you have 10 water
molecules in a certain unit
cell and you evolve them with
the Newton equation of motion,
you can obviously know that
the number of molecules
and the volume of the unit
cell are not going to change.
And if you integrate
your equation
of motion appropriately, the
total energy of the system,
that is the kinetic energy
plus the potential energy,
is not going to change.
And so as we evolve this
point in phase space,
its trajectory is going
to span what we call
the microcanonical ensemble.
And you let this point
evolve long enough.
And all of a sudden, you will
have a meaningful trajectory,
that is a meaningful assembly
collection of microstates
of representative configurations
in space and in velocities
of your system, out of which
you can calculate averages
of any of the observables
that you want to calculate
and that you want
to characterize.
So what do you do in these
molecular dynamic simulations?
Well, there are really
four important steps
that you need to
take into account.
And we keep thinking of water,
liquid water, as an example.
That is, you need to
start from something.
That is, you need
to put your water
molecule in a certain position.
And you need to give
them initial velocities.
And you are almost never
going to be good enough
in choosing a state of
the system that is somehow
meaningful.
You'll always, when you start
building something complex,
put molecules in places that
they don't want to stay.
And one needs to be very
careful, then, in all of this.
But suppose that we have, in any
case, an initial configuration
of position and velocity.
Then what we need to do is,
over and over again, integrate
the equation of motion, that
is, from the current position
and the current velocities,
predict the new position
after a certain time.
And once you have the new
position at a certain time,
you can recalculate what
are the forces acting
on the particle in
the new position.
And with these forces,
you can, again,
move the particles by a certain
amount and so on and so forth.
And that is where the
molecular dynamics
algorithm comes into play.
We need to integrate
our equation of motion.
And with this, our system
will start to evolve.
We have put that point
in phase space in motion.
And it'll start moving around.
And if we are
integrating correctly,
the total energy of the system
is going to be conserved.
Now what we need
to do is we need
to make sure that
our characterization,
our thermodynamic
averages, do not depend
on our initial condition.
Again, we have started
from a configuration
that we have built by hand.
And because of that,
it's most likely
a very unfavorable
configuration of the system.
OK, so we need to let the
system evolve and somehow start
figuring out really
in which condition
it would want to stay.
Think of the previous example
of silicon that is glassifying.
Well, we had liquid silicon.
We have to cool it down.
In a way, what's happening
is that we are never
equilibrating it because the
system goes into a glass phase.
And so it never loses memory
of its initial condition.
It's always sort of trapped in
this pseudo liquid, now glass,
state.
While in reality,
at a temperature
below the freezing
or the melting point,
equilibrium would be given
by a crystalline state
with the ions vibrating.
So there are cases in
which equilibration
is so difficult that we
actually never reach it.
Silicon never goes to a crystal.
That's why we need
to be careful.
But in most cases
awfully we are lucky.
And we lose memory
of initial condition.
Say, the opposite is actually
very easy to achieve.
If we start from the
solid and we warm it up,
it becomes a liquid.
And if we wait long
enough, that liquid
will have lost all memory
of having come from a solid.
OK, so it's actually very
easy in one direction
and very difficult in
the other direction.
But once this equilibration time
has passed, well, at that point
we have truly
everything in place.
Our point in phase
space is moving around.
And it's really going into the
regions of high probability
and distributed, according
to Boltzmann distribution.
And so at that point,
we can start an average
among any of the
physical observables
that we want to calculate.
And so there are
these four phases.
And I'll briefly mention
how we actually choose them.
Initialization.
Well, again, we need
position and velocities.
You need to be
careful, in particular,
to avoid overlap
between your molecules.
If you put two atoms
very close, they
are going to repel each other
with an enormous strength.
And if you put
them close enough,
they are going to shoot
in opposite directions
very quickly and completely
kick off and mess up
everything on the side.
So what is difficult is really,
always in configuration space,
finding the right structures.
This is the difficult part of
choosing initial condition.
Choosing velocities
is much easier.
One possibility is just
giving zero velocity
to the system or a
very small velocity
and then slowly adding things.
And what we usually see is that
configuration in velocity space
is much faster.
And this is the reason.
Think of that trajectory for
a moment of one particle.
And think of what happens
when you have a collision.
Suppose that you have
particles, for a moment, that
are hard spheres.
In a collision, the
velocity of the particle
all of a sudden changes sign.
So in the velocity part
of the phase space,
your point makes
a sudden jump, OK,
because the velocity that
was plus 10 has become
all of a sudden minus 10.
So in velocity space,
for the limit case
of a system of hard spheres,
your representative point
hops everywhere continuously.
In reality, I mean, you have
interaction at all times.
And you don't really hop.
But you can sort of
move very quickly
from one region to
the other region.
There is not anything similar
to the glass entanglement
in configuration space.
So it's very easy to
thermalize velocity.
It's very difficult to
thermalize and equilibrate
position.
And that's where, all,
you need to be careful.
And if you really
want to be accurate,
what you can also do
instead of giving zero
velocity to your system,
you can use your concept
of statistical mechanics.
That is, a system of
classical particles
will have a distribution
of velocities
that depends on the
temperature at which it is.
And this is 0 in Celsius.
So it's 273 Kelvin.
And the distribution of
velocity in a classical system
is actually given by the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution
written above that has
basically this shape.
So it means that if we are,
say, at 0 Celsius, 273 Kelvin,
we'll have a lot of molecules
with a certain velocity.
And then, in
principle, we can have
molecules with higher
and higher velocity.
But the probability of
finding them decreases.
And as we increase
the temperature,
the probability distribution
of the velocities
for the molecules changes.
And so as usual, you can define
both a median or an average
in your system.
That is, you can look at what is
the most likely velocity, that
is the top of this
curve, at 0 Celsius.
Or you could also define
what is the average velocity.
And since that this
curve is asymmetric,
it's going to be really
shifted a little bit.
And these are actually
the numerical expressions
for these two velocities,
the most likely
and the average velocity.
And so I've given you the
example of an oxygen molecule
at room temperature.
We are talking about
1,000 meters per second.
So these velocities,
if you want,
are similar to the speed
of sound in your material
because, at the end, sound
propagates at a certain speed
because that's the velocity
of the collision from one
molecule to the next that are
really carrying sound away.
So if you want to
be sophisticated,
you give to your system
a set of velocities
that could be, say, all
identical to the most likely
velocity.
But again, equilibration
and thermalization
in velocity space is very easy.
So once you have this,
that is, once you
have a set of positions
and the set of velocities,
you need to use Newton's
equation of motion of saying,
of predicting, where your
system is going to go.
And so that's when the
molecular dynamic algorithm
comes into play.
So what you need to
do is, as we say,
you need to use an integrator,
the algorithm that tells you
what your next position and
what your next velocities
are going to be.
And there are a
number of integrators.
There are subtleties.
But often you find the
name of Verlet algorithm.
This is one class of algorithms.
And the other common class is
the Gear predictor-corrector,
just to give you
the terminology.
And we look, in a moment,
at the Verlet algorithm.
They're all fairly simple.
But what is really important
is that this algorithm
should be robust.
That is, they should give
you a trajectory that
is very close to the
trajectory that you would
get from the perfect
analytical integration
of the equation of motion.
And in particular, what is
the most important thing
is that they should be
accurate in, say, conserving
the constant of motion.
As we have seen from the
Newton's equation of motion,
the sum of the kinetic energy
and the potential energy
should be a constant.
If your integration, if
your numerical evaluation,
of that equation
is poor, you will
see that the constant of motion
is not any more constant.
So again, this is
the sanity check
on the accuracy of
your integration.
And there are more
subtle elements
of the integration algorithm
that can become important.
But we won't go into that.
And then as I said,
straightforward integration
of the Newton's
equation of motion
gives you the microcanonical
ensemble in which
the total energy's conserved.
But sometimes you want
to study systems in which
the temperature is fixed.
Or you could want
to study systems
in which the pressure is fixed.
And so you need to augment your
molecular dynamic integrator
with some feature that
allows you to control
those intensive variables.
So if you want, say, to control
the temperature of the system,
what we say usually is
that we couple the system
to a thermostat.
That is, we make sure that the
temperature in your evolution
doesn't change.
And you'll see examples
in the next class of this.
And in the case, in
particular, of something,
say, like the temperature,
you have a whole set
of possible thermostats.
That is, you could use
stochastic approaches.
That is, you have your
evolution of your system.
And your system
doesn't conserve,
if it's microcanonical,
the temperature.
Sometimes it goes towards
higher temperature.
Sometimes it go towards
lower temperature.
And what you could do is
either every now and then
absorb some energy or give back
some energy in your system--
and that would be a
Langevin dynamics--
in order to control the average
kinetic energy of your system.
Or you could somehow forbid, in
the microcanonical evolution,
your system to choose a state in
which the temperature changes.
So if your new positions are
such that your velocity gives
an increase in
temperature, you just
shorten how much your
atoms move in order
to make the velocity
smaller and in order
to make the kinetic
energy conserved.
Or there are more
complex dynamical ways
of imposing
temperature that goes
under the name of
extended Hamiltonian,
or extended system,
of which we'll see
an example that is [INAUDIBLE].
But let me give you really
what is the simplest and still
one of the most used
numerical integrators.
And it tends to be very
robust and very accurate.
So it's still used in a lot of
molecular dynamic simulations.
And there is often no reason to
do anything better than this.
So in a way, we are in
a much luckier situation
than in quantum mechanics.
This is good enough
in almost all cases.
And this is how we
look at the problem.
That is, what we
need to do always
is we need to calculate the
position of each particle
at a time t plus
delta t once we know
the position, the
velocity, and the forces
on that particle at time t.
So suppose I'm at a certain
instant in time that I call t.
I know everything about my
system-- position, velocity,
and forces.
What I really need
to do is predict
what are the new positions.
And when I'm in
the new positions,
I want to calculate the forces
again and evolve the system.
And now, what do we do?
Well, let's do a simple
Taylor expansion.
That is, this is r of t is a
function of the variable t.
So we can use a
Taylor expansion.
And r of t plus delta
t is going to be r of t
plus the derivative of r with
respect to t times delta t.
And that's the velocity.
Plus 1/2 of the
second derivative
of the position with
respect to time.
And that's the acceleration.
Times delta t squared, and so
on for the third derivatives
and so on for the fourth,
fifth, ad infinitum.
This is just the Taylor
expansion as a function, OK?
And so it gives us the
position of t plus delta t,
knowing all the derivatives--
first, second, third, fourth,
nth--
at times t.
And once we have
the derivatives,
we can not only predict
what the position would
be at t plus delta t, but
also what the position would
be at t minus delta t.
And it's written here.
And if you think, the
terms with an odd power
change sign in delta t.
And the terms with an even power
in delta t do not change sign.
So we have just done
a Taylor expansion.
And now what we do is we
actually sum these two
quantities together, OK?
And this is what we obtain, OK?
We sum the two
quantities together.
All the odd terms disappear.
This sums to 0.
The fifth order, seventh
order, and so on sum to 0.
So what we have is that we
have rt plus delta t plus rt
minus delta t is equal to
2 times rt plus alpha--
sorry-- acceleration
times delta t squared.
It's just written here.
And then rearrange the terms.
But you see, this is
the Verlet algorithm.
Now what we have when we
look at this expression,
we have an expression
that tells us
what is the position
at my new time step,
knowing the position
at my current instant,
knowing the position at
the previous instant.
We are keeping configurations
from our trajectories.
So we know where we were before.
We know where we are now.
And we know where
we are going to be
just by adding to this
the term acceleration
at the present time
times delta t squared.
We make an error
because we are not
introducing terms
that are higher
order in delta t squared.
But you see, the term in delta
t cubed has canceled out.
So the error that we make
is just of the order delta t
fourth.
That is, that means that the
smaller we make the delta t,
the smaller we make the
time step, the more accurate
our integration is.
And so this is, if you want
the most critical parameter
in your molecular
dynamic simulation,
you need to make sure that
the steps that you take
are small enough,
considering what is really
the variation of your
force as a function of time
because remember
that now that we use
Newton's equation of motion,
the acceleration at a time t
is just given by the
force divided by the mass.
And because the force is just
the gradient of the potential,
it's just given by this.
So at a certain
instant in time t,
you have the acceleration
acting in your particles
just by taking the force
and dividing by the mass.
So at every instant,
you calculate force.
And the force lets
you evolve the system.
And it keeps giving
you the new positions.
And so you know what is the
trajectory and configuration
space.
And you can very
simply find out what
is your velocity
at every instant t,
if you need to calculate
what is the velocity just
by doing a final difference
calculation of the tangent
basically.
The velocity is the
tangent of the trajectory
with respect to t.
OK, this concludes class.
What we'll see in
the next lecture
is how we actually take
this Verlet integration
and how we use it to
do the characterization
of the thermodynamic
properties of a real system.
So today is Thursday.
Next week is spring break.
So we'll see each other
again on Tuesday, 29th.
And I will be at a conference.
And all the TAs will be
at a conference next week.
So it will be slightly difficult
communicating via email.
So try to ask a lot of
questions between now
and Sunday for your problem
set that is due the Tuesday
after spring break.
And that will be problem set 2.
Otherwise, enjoy spring break.